what i did was i drop shipped
supplements because i couldn't afford
stock so
uh for anyone that's listening that
doesn't know what drop shipping is it's
basically when you
you sell a product on your website or
your business that you don't actually
own so people buy off you you buy off
someone else after they've made the
order and you make a small margin
so that was my sort of creative way to
try and
understand how i could transact online
before actually investing sort of
decent capital into the business oh
sneaky okay that's smart and so you did
that at the same time
and then saved up and bought a printing
press and a sewing machine
and started making clothes yeah because
if i'm honest right so as a kid i just
loved fitness this is
i sound like such a nerd but i would go
to the events right and
i would just love them i would walk
around just in awe of everyone there
because fitness genuinely changed my
entire life it just changed the
trajectory of it in every single way
so for me it wasn't even about the
business it was just about i wanted to
be involved in any way that i could so
if it was drop shipping products i'm
making one pound profit on a 50 pound
order
which isn't you know it's not scalable
in any way shape or form
i was happy with that because i just
wanted to be involved and i wanted to
somehow connect with my heroes
okay um can you get into how fitness
changed your life you said it changed
everything so what exactly happened so i
at school so i wasn't i wasn't naughty
by any stretch of the imagination i
wasn't i didn't like mess up about
but i just wasn't particularly
interested in it it never really spoke
to me
and i've seemed to realize now i think
my personality is
i'm very much a creative person i'm i
did i did um
i did the personality test and it came
through with like a zero
percentile conscious conscientiousness
or something crazy no
way so you you've man that's insane so
you've managed to
that goes against everything my dad
believes in so you've managed to grow up
i did that test right i did that test
and i realized so robin my fiance i
showed her
i was i was heartbroken when i did that
test i was so emotional and i left it
out on the side
it's like i don't know it's like seven
or eight pages i left it out the side i
didn't want to look at it
and then robin read it and i was really
annoyed and i was like robin why why are
you reading my stuff i don't want you to
read that because i didn't think it was
true and she
said it was the most true thing she's
ever read about me
and in that i was a zero in on the
conscientiousness scale
so i thought after that i'm like right
i'm terrible at this i'm going to
outsource
all conscientiousness in my life and
i've done that and it's that's been
brilliant but
um sorry going back to school i wasn't i
wasn't particularly great at school
and um then i went to the gym and when i
went to the gym one of the guys there
put me on a
on a regime right you turn up five days
a week you do chest on this day legs on
this day
oh that time back on this day shoulders
on this day and with all due respect ben
however tired miserable whatever you
feel you turn up and you do it because
that's the way that it works here and i
just did it and then i realized that if
i applied that to school
and just turned up and did it regardless
of how i was feeling
then i actually got decent results and
before that if i was a bit tired or
miffed or something that annoyed me that
morning
or whatever i just wouldn't bother uh so
that was the main thing that the gym
taught me
okay this is fascinating we have to go
back to this personality thing because
you've managed to grow a
insanely successful business and you
scored low in conscientiousness
so what were your open do you remember
your openness scores
uh it was high i don't know how high but
it was high
okay okay so from from what i've learned
from my dad a lot of people who end up
being low in conscientiousness and super
high
in openness can end up outsourcing and
just figuring out workarounds
so let me think where do i want to go
from here
how did you figure out what to outsource
uh
so i'll start by saying i was massively
lucky
so i've i'm like i'm the luckiest but
i'm so lucky it's unbelievable
so i've met so many people that have
completely changed my life
and some of the people that i've met are
the polar opposites of me right so
so that's that was quite easy for me to
then outsource and there were people
that i ended up trusting with my
my life so to outsource that to them as
was a little bit heartbreaking and
difficult at the start but over time as
i got used to it as i was sort of
positively reinforced so
i'll sort of i'm using the term
outsource i would ask someone to help me
with something
they would do a better job than me that
would then give me confidence to give
them more
and more and more and more so that
certainly helped um
but i was also really lucky i think i'm
i'm quite inquisitive person so when i
was in the gym
even as a teenager i would just would
use the term here like peck
people's heads right i would just go and
ask them questions there was like
the business guy or the guy that was
good at this or the person that was good
at this and i would just go to them and
i would just say
which is weird because i'm massively
introverted um
i would just go and ask them questions
and just learn and learn and learn and i
i try and be as much of a sponge as
physically possible
so anyway through doing that i ended up
meeting up meeting some brilliant
brilliant people
who essentially helped me to develop my
weaker points and
this is the thing that i've been really
fortunate to do
is when the business started to grow i
brought in people early
people that were very very different to
me and much better at me at their
respective things
so i'm going to give you an example i
was really poor at finance
operations people management public
speaking all of these things
um but the people i brought in were
incredible at these things
so as an example finance right
i could have a go at finance without
these people and nine times out of ten i
would fail one time out of ten i would
probably do okay
but since those people were in i could
give it a go fail at it
and then they would just fix it because
they are way better right than me or
i would know they were doing it and i
would learn and learn and learn so the
way i explain it i was chatting to some
guys at university here the other week
the way i had i built it in business was
or i was fortunate enough to build it in
business because the people around me
is it's almost like being able to take
the same exam over and over and over
again until
you get the grade that you want because
i can just keep trying these things that
i'm not very good at but because i've
got really good people around me they
can then
fix it and then the business in no way
slows down because of it
does that make sense that does make
sense uh how
how did you afford to bring these people
in
so they were so that we really started
to bring people in after about
two years in the business um
the the way that we afforded i would say
to bring those people in was we were in
the right place at the right time
like the stars aligned right so people
were
on social media more than ever people
all of a sudden about eight years ago
seemed to get comfortable buying direct
to consumer from online businesses that
they'd never heard of
um and you know the whole again
influence of marketing and everything
that came with it just really was a
thing and by the way the whole
like so much of the western world or it
felt like this being from the uk
there was this point in the early 2000s
where like people were talking about
obesity everywhere
so as you get into 2010 11 and 12
everyone then started to shift towards
fitness
so all these stars certainly aligned so
we
had a we had difficult first six to 12
months as a business but then year one
two and three after that we started to
you know
really do well um we had like three or
four occasions where we risked every
penny that we had on things that
happened to go really well for us which
then brought money into the business
which allowed us to invest in great
people
okay can you give me some examples about
of those risks
so we i said at the start that we used
to go to these fitness expos
again going back to start aligning right
i was born here in the west midlands
about 20 minutes away from where i was
born one of the i think at the time it
was
hands down the best fitness event in
europe is ran at the birmingham or what
was around the birmingham and you see
over the road
um so i would go there as a kid just to
be around these fitness people right
so i was there one day and i had this
massive
massive like gut-wrenching feeling that
we had to be there
which is weird because we could in no
way afford it right and i was like
i don't know what it looks like at the
time we didn't even make clothes we were
just dropshipping supplements i was like
we have to be here so i literally went
and this was like
i think about an hour before i had to
get back from my shifted pizza we went
up to the to the stand where you booked
the stands
and there was a guy who's actually now
one of my sort of close friends
and he ran the event and he happened to
be there and i said listen
we need to stand here next year give us
can we have your smallest stand and he
said yeah that's fine we've got
availability it's 12 months in advance
it's going to cost you
it was a few thousand pounds and we
didn't actually have that money at the
time but
i'd sort of back myself over the next 12
months that we could we could fill that
gap
um so we booked that event and we'd
spent basically everything we had on
that we then had to then really invest
in
you know the stand itself the people
flying over and that event went
incredibly incredibly well and it was a
huge pivotal moment in the history of
the brand
but then after that event did well we
were like right boom let's do it again
and again and again and then we flew to
ohio and we did an event in ohio we did
los angeles we did melbourne australia
we did germany cologne we did bourbon
birmingham again so we went from zero to
60 very quickly and again we invested
every single penny we had time and time
again in things that
i guess we've really really believed in
okay so do you think well that sounds
like you've got a pretty good
what intuition about business choices
either or we're incredibly lucky yeah
yeah it's very difficult to tell i would
say that people underestimate intuition
like i think i've been thinking about
that a lot and i think that
your brain is so capable of taking in so
many factors around you
that you can't consciously figure out
and so you're making all these decisions
that you're not actually thinking about
it
and i think that's what your intuition
is when you get that really strong
feeling that something's wrong or that
something's going to work i think it's
just
you haven't figured out how to put it
into words that's what i would like to
believe anyway